[Music]
so welcome to net three or three living
on the edge I actually wanted to have
that song playing but to us not to be
just a quick reminder please do fill out
the Dory if you have questions that's
how we will be in taking questions of
course there are microphones here if you
want to have just a live Q&A it'll
really help us sort of record the
questions and see what kinds of
interests folks have in the field and
with that let's go into introductions so
my name is sort of Gupta
I am a p.m. on cloud CDN and with me
here is esteemed friend and colleague
Brian I'm Brian Rogan I'm Senior
Director at Google for CDN and
engineering for the internet facing
network as well as interconnect so I
think I'm gonna take it away from here
and walk you through our agenda we're
gonna talk a little bit about you know
the background of Google CDN I'll take
you through a little bit about how it
works under the hood and and how we
think about the content delivery problem
at Google so Rob is gonna take you
through how to actually get everything
up and running yourself and then we'll
talk a little bit about security and and
how you can use what we built to be
successful in your business so to start
off and I think one of the things that
TK talked about a lot on Tuesday all the
way way back when at the beginning was
about openness and and Google Cloud is
about openness and ours and CDN at
Google is no different
well today we're gonna talk primarily
about our first party see an offering we
work with a series of amazing CDN
interconnect partners who can offer you
preferential pricing on cash flow so
that at Google you know you're gonna
have the CDN that satisfies your needs
best
it's not about locking it's not about
kind of pushing you towards us it's
about the choice that works for you to
talk about where we see kind of Google
CDN being different first off I think it
comes down a lot to performance that's
kind of our headline that's what we've
been working on a lot of Google over the
last decade in CDN is you know how do we
have the the broadest reach the deepest
the deepest kind of connectivity and
great performance and and I think the
the number sort of speak for themselves
here both in terms of
put and latency so we think we really
have a best-in-class product on CDN when
you think about performance and you
think about how to reach your users all
over the globe we think the products
also really marked by simplicity so Rob
will take you through this in a lot more
depth but you can turn on CDN at Google
with a single checkbox and and with that
checkbox you get all of our deployment
you get you can reach all around the
world and you get us CDN you get caching
and let's look at that reach um so you
we have 134 points of presence and and
again for the last north of a decade
we've been investing in our physical
infrastructure and in in the network
that's gonna get you around the world
and catch you close to your users again
we'll dive actually a fair bit deeper
into this and and how we think about
this part of the problem but along with
that you also get scale and you get to
you get the infrastructure that Google
uses for its own first party services
and we have seven products with with
over a billion users each all around the
world and again we'll dive a little bit
deeper on on how we think about that
part of the problem so to jump in a
little bit and talk about our network
architecture I wanna I want to kind of
reflect back on on when we started this
journey at Google you know then the year
was 2006 we had we had just acquired
YouTube and at that time if you could
make it through a YouTube video without
it rebuffering
it was like a small miracle you know we
kind of celebrate
I ruined many a Friday night social
gathering by by trying to watch YouTube
with friends you know popping out my TCP
dump and grabbing logs when things
didn't work is super awkward experience
for everyone involved I was not invited
back but if you flash forward a decade
right I think one of our one of our
greatest accomplishments is the fact
that for the vast majority of users and
for the vast majority of workloads now
connectivity blends into the background
right
I watched the Super Bowl on YouTube TV
five seconds behind the mez feed for
three hours without a rebuff ur right
this year right and and as a user I
didn't even think about that right I
just assumed that that would work right
and so I think what we've seen over over
this time is like an absolutely
transformative experience in terms of
what it means to be on the receiving end
of content delivery and I think what
that means for you for our customers is
that all of a sudden you can build all
of these amazing experiences where
connectivity just gets out of the way
right where the users are not distracted
by the fact that things are a buffering
they're not distracted by waiting they
can really engage with with your content
and and they can really kind of work
closely with your business so I wanted
to talk a little bit about you know how
we think about the content delivery
problem and what got us here just just
to give you some background about what's
underneath the hood of that single check
box so when we think about how to reach
the globe you know step one is it's kind
of the obvious you need to go where the
users are and so the main challenge of
the content is every problem is is kind
of content lives in data centers and
users live everywhere right and so the
goal is to figure out how we can with
the best performance possible get your
content from our data centers directly
into the last mile and to your users you
know devices and into their homes and so
first thing first we go where the
internet is we work with we work with
anybody we connect to the vast majority
of of networks of last mile user
user-facing networks on the globe
directly and that's a point of pride of
ours and it's it's a core part of how we
got here and how we built what we have
we run it at massive scale at at Google
scale and so again the cloud CDN product
is a product that leverages all of the
scale of the infrastructure that we
built at Google and you kind of ride
along and you get that for free and
finally I'll talk a little bit about
this we've spent the last few years
figuring out how can we innovate in the
content delivery problem how can we
innovate a network and how can we make
it so that you really have a very unique
set of capabilities here that push
forward the whole Internet just to go
back again you know and to talk about
that that kind of that content delivery
problem you you know kind of where our
data centers are you also have a sense
of kind of in all of our edge points of
presence or our places where we have CDN
caching and so I thought maybe it would
be kind of cool to take you through a
little bit of the journey of like how
your content starts at a data center and
how it gets out to the Internet so I
figured I would start with this
beautiful slide of one of our data
centers at sunrise and well it is it is
gorgeous and I would love to be there
you will notice there are not a great
many users there and so that's sort of
one of the central challenges right of
that in general data centers on the
Internet are placed in places where you
can acquire you know a couple
takers and like a gigawatt of power
right not not necessarily right in the
middle of kind of city centers and and I
think this is an important kind of
insight because if you think about how
the Internet is provisioned right how
the internet works it's all around kind
of the centers of population it's all
around the places that you'd want to go
out on a Friday night right the New
York's and London's and Paris's of the
world right and so there's there's quite
a journey to sometimes be had from where
your content lives to where your users
are so it starts at the data centers
right but at Google and I think you know
compared to some other people content
delivery is a ground-up problem for us
right and if we literally think about it
as how do we get from where your where
your content lives from where your
workloads live all the way through to
the Internet and and so here we have
some pictures of some of the
construction this is all first party
stuff that we've done at Google and up
on the top left which i think is really
cool is burying a sparing duct bank and
and you'll see there there's a whole
bunch of conduits and they actually get
strung together in a in a metal frame to
make that cool square and then we didn't
show the part where they fill the whole
thing in with concrete like miles and
miles and miles of concrete and and so I
mean it just think that in this world
right it's it's just it's a this is an
intensely physical process right that's
one of things I like to kind of remark
about in in CDN right is that for most
people the Internet is this very
ethereal thing it kind of like lives off
in the cloud right but in our world I
mean it's it's concrete and conduit and
pulling fiber right and it is a it is a
very physical thing on the bottom right
you have a little bit more of an easier
kind of long-haul Pole with a little bit
less fiber where we actually just do
kind of open trenching that we cover in
but again these are the kinds of
physical investments that power this
network that you see obviously we have a
significant subsea investments 13 subsea
investments that we've done either
through consortium or with other folks
and and if you've never seen how
submarine cable is laid it is one of the
most mind-blowing things that I have
seen in my life I mean we have a
gigantic cable ship that literally runs
cable across the entire ocean lays it
down on the ocean floor through through
kind of valleys and ridges trying to
figure out how we can make sure that we
have a clean path on underneath the
ocean
but the craziest part is it's like not
just passive right like all of this this
this light needs to be repeated every
hundred kilometers or so and so there's
literally active equipment that lives
underwater and when these things break
or when they need to be fixed right
recent UAVs down and pull the cable up
and the cable tents for miles right
because of trigonometry so these are
these kind of just absolutely amazing
things that happen under the hood all
kind of sight unseen to you the user of
our of our service then when we talk
about ok what does it mean to like to
meet the Internet where it is right the
Internet is all around the world and so
these are this is actually what may be
one of our our 134 pops looks like right
and you'll notice compared to the next
slide everything here is very clean and
cabled but but in the bottom right this
is actually what one of our one of our
peer facing fabrics looks like right
just just cabled up and and the thing
that you have to keep in mind again it's
just the scale right like these are sort
of two routers that are part of the
fabric in one of the 134 pops right and
so this is just a massive massive
globally distributed infrastructure and
with just you know hundreds of thousands
of pairs of fiber all of them
meticulously labeled you'll note which
is I don't know how anyone has the
patience to do that but but I thank them
for and so that's that's kind of what
the physical infrastructure looks like
on the ground and all of that is to
actually meet the internet right and so
you'll notice now we're kind of outside
of space that's controlled by Google but
when you think about how the internet
actually works in the real world right
it's literally about two different
networks connecting to one another
physically right and so we're actually
creating an optical path between say
Google and in Newark that can help us
deliver that content and it's sometimes
a messy business this is a MeetMe room
at one of our one of our colocation
facilities where we're basically
networks that connect to user traffic
and Google will actually meet up make up
make a fiber pass and kind of link back
to our to our infrastructure so this is
sort of the messy business of how the
internet works under the hood and I
think just to talk a little bit about
this is the result is it's kind of what
you see with Google Network tiers right
this is the premium network that that we
keep talking about it and what it means
right we're where you can actually ride
our first party infrastructure right
from your data center all the way to the
end-user we also offer for more kind of
value minded customer
or for workloads that don't necessarily
need the performance of that premium
tier a standard tier product which rides
over the Internet and doesn't
necessarily get to take advantage of all
of that that privately built
infrastructure but you can see the
difference right like when we look at
what does it mean to be on that premium
network you know in this particular test
you know we can actually see an almost
2x improvement in throughput right and
so those ground-up investments right
really really matter right and again I
think that's that's for me the main
takeaway here right is that when you
come to Google you have an
infrastructure that's built literally
from the dirt right up to give you the
best performance and you can see it I
want to talk a little bit about - you
know what what we were busy doing on the
software side for that that decade to
get us there right and here we also I
think had a lot of really interesting
innovations over that time one of the
areas that we've worked a lot in because
there's such high leverage is area of
transport you know how so the protocols
that actually make sure we can reliably
deliver traffic over the Internet
so quick is something we've invested a
lot of energy and over time it
originated here although it's an open
standard you know used by these many
people you know we worked a lot on how
do we get latency down and so we have
the zero RTT handshake that allows you
to kind of quickly establish a
connection to Google and you can see
what it meant to us like when we flipped
on quick and mass we saw a significant
improvement in throughput across the
board and so I think this has been
really like one of the key drivers of
sort of innovation of the protocol level
for us we also worked a lot on
congestion control and that was that was
agnostic to TCP and quic both implement
congestion avoidance protocol that we
call bbr and that works on the insight
that whereas classic you know TCP Kubik
for example well back off when it notice
is lost and then it work bbr uses the
insight that in a modern network the
routers have very deep buffers and so
you can actually tell that things are
starting to get full by noticing the
packets spaced out more and more and you
can use that as a signal that the
network is congested and back off and it
turns out in the modern internet for
many use cases it's actually a much more
reliable signal of the available
throughput on a link and so what we can
actually see here is that when we use
bbr we can achieve significantly higher
throughput in the presence of the kind
of sporadic loss that happens on the
internet over over the same RTT
and so those were kind of two things
that I wanted to dive deeper on but but
again I think it's important to know at
Google that the innovation and the
network is something that we have been
doing consistently over the last the
last decade a couple of things that are
particularly cool for CDN are our Google
global cache deployments that live all
around the world espresso which is our
internet facing Software Defined
Networking stack and and so if you can
imagine in real time one of the things
that we do is we we figure out exactly
how traffic is gonna flow across that
network that Google operates and how
it's gonna flow through the Internet we
try to make sure that we never overload
any link we monitor in real time again
all in software every minute to see
where there's any degradation in
performance to certain parts of the
Internet and how we can use that broad
footprint to route traffic around it and
so as this also I think has been one of
the key things this proprietary traffic
management system that has enabled us to
really push the bar and make things
better at Google so with that I want to
hand it over to see ok you know we have
this amazing infrastructure so we'd like
to think and and how do you actually set
it up and how do you get all that
simplicity thank you all right so set up
and use how do you get started how do
you make this work for you so let's take
a look at that first we'll start by
seeing what a traditional CDN looks like
and how it thinks of the world you will
start with the grid there is actually a
gray box around here so use your
imaginations there is a gray box which
is a regional data center and in that
you have some kind of virtual machine or
some kind of a an object store which is
fronted by a load balancer which is then
fronted by a regional IP that regional
IP is advertised through the regional
public network and that's why if you
have sort of multi region deployments
you will then have that same deployment
across different data centers each one
will have their own load balancer each
one will have their own sort of regional
IP and then they will plug into the
public network that is proximal to that
data center which means you really need
to layer a wrapper of caching around all
this right so you will then have a
separate layer
of caching that exists at the edge which
means if a user let's say in LA wants to
connect to your content they will do if
they're using your domain name they will
look up some kind of DNS entry they will
find the IP that creates a path to your
cache endpoint and then also the caching
infrastructure will need to know where
to get that data from so at some level
they will have to back into the public
network again go through their public IP
fine find the the load balance etc and
serve that content back out the same
path so really there's lots of hops this
is going through the public network this
is going to a public network right and
also at the edge you have a fair amount
of complexity in configuration in terms
of IP based load balancing or DNS based
load balancing etcetera so so this is
kind of like a summary right multiple
DNS lookups CDN is a separate system
from your serving infrastructure
regional constructs with again regional
IDs if you look at how Google approached
it
we said let's again because we have that
again global construct to our VP sees
our load balancers actually sit at the
edge right they're not I mean part of
their infrastructure is at the edge
itself and this is our Google Fiber that
Brian gave you a preview on so when you
have to get data out of Google you have
a global anycast IP so it's broadcast
out of all these endpoints and you can
figure out the fastest path to that
endpoint you then ingress at the edge
location the load balancer figures out
how to route the traffic efficiently
through the backbone to where the data
is actually stored you traverse this
private fiber path again also to the
private you you traverse this private
fiber path to the correct data center
you get your data and you then traverse
that back out so what you get are
distributed constructs all the way
through right you get distributed load
balancing distributed caching and
distribute it SSL at the edge
there's another cool thing that happens
here so the ssl will be advertised out
of this end point so your front end will
have your domain based ssl and let's say
you say you know what i want this to
simply serve HTTP to my load balancer
front end that will still be an
encrypted transit path Google just going
to encrypt that in transit so you don't
have to explicitly create an SSL
infrastructure to have this edge traffic
reach here you obviously can you can
have self-signed keys you can have all
those types of things but in general by
putting SSL at the edge you start to get
all the benefits of quick and HTTP to
the fast handshake negotiation etc and
you get a fairly secure part not rail
you get a secure pipe all the way
through to where your data is stored
so let's actually see how some of this
works so here I have an Origin which is
a bucket of data can we switch to the
demo and here's the bucket so the bucket
is public it's called public as the data
in it is public but the bucket itself is
private you cannot list it or sort of
browse it and here we have all the
different objects that are that we will
be serving so these are all mp4 - or
MPEG - chunks and here you can see sort
of the you can see the metadata for it
where at the at the object level I'm
setting the cache control so there I've
said this is public and it's TTL is
about 20 minutes just lights so here
you've seen the bucket you've seen the
chunks and you saw how we set the
metadata at the object level to mark it
public with a certain cache value so now
let's actually set up this
infrastructure and see what it looks
like so we'll be going back and forth
between the demo and the slides for a
bit so let's create the anycast IP that
you just saw so if I go to my
PC networks and again I'll just take one
moment to highlight what this looks like
in real life when you log into the
console you will see here it's one V PC
that's my default V PC but it's got ten
dot IP addresses in every single region
right which means if I need to send
traffic from here to there I don't
really need to do any kind of transit
link I just go from one ten dollar
address to another $10 address and it
just traverses so that's that's sort of
the whole global network and premium
network and all those constructs that we
were talking about so let's go ahead and
create one of those fancy IP addresses
you were talking about reserved static
IP address and let's call this the demo
CDN IP we want the premium Network ipv4
that's fine and we want a global global
IP so let's go ahead and click reserved
it's gonna take a few seconds while it
spins and it's going to give us after
that an IP address that we can use can
we switch to the slides
Thanks so we did we did that part right
we figured out a way that a end client
can look up an IP address and and get to
us but we didn't create a DNS entry so
let's do that next so here our IP
address is created I have the address
let's copy that let's go to our network
services cloud DNS and I have a CDN zone
where on a certain domain I've sort of
directed the name servers here so I'll
add a record set and I'm gonna give it
let's say demo and I'm gonna put in the
anycast IP that we had captured and we
hit create so here I now have a DNS
entry that maps to that IP address that
we just created let's switch back cool
so our front-end is kinda sorta done
now let's create the load balancer so
the load balancer is gonna do a couple
of things it's gonna say here's my
front-end I want you to serve out of
this IP address and you know we need to
attach this the SSL that represents that
domain name that we just created so
let's do that
so here's in network services here's my
load balancer click and let's create a
little balancer and of course this is
going to be an HTTP load balancer so
let's click that
select start configuration and we were
going to do the front-end so here let's
call it demo CDN load balancer for an
end we want HTTP and it's going to be
using premium and we created this IP
address so it's going to let us select
that port 443 now we need to attach a
certificate where is that gonna come
from so let's create a new one so let's
call it demo CD n lb SSL Certificates
and here I can actually just select
Google managed so I really don't have to
figure out what was that open SSL
command or you know how do I create my
CSR and where do I send it and and those
types of things and you know it makes it
really easy to get an SSL up and running
right and so here's a manage SSL I hit
create and that starts to create the
certificate that will then get attached
to my front-end load balancer so here
I'm saying the SSL policies defaults and
quick negotiation is automatic so
without really doing a lot the front-end
will automatically try to detect how
advanced your client is and if it can
support some of these more advanced
protocols and it will negotiate the
fastest way to get a handshake going and
and establish a connection so that's
done
can we switch so so far we created the
front end and we attacks the SSL to it
now what we have to do is create the
back end right so once the traffic
arrives on that IP and SSL is negotiated
etc the traffic has to go somewhere to
get the data where does it go we created
that bucket and so we're going to make
that bucket a back-end service that the
load balancer will direct traffic to and
the back it could be a bucket it could
be a VM you don't really have to I mean
you can choose either one and this we're
just using a bucket so that makes it
simpler so switch to the demo so here in
that same load balancer now let me
actually give it a name
demo CDN one so here's my back-end and I
don't have any services attached so
let's create a back-end bucket which is
specifically a serving bucket now let's
do demo CDN back-end bucket right and
select the bucket that we want which is
this one select and again if you recall
we had shown that simplicity which is
that checkbox right there so once we
click that it will actually activate
caching at the edge when this service
becomes live on the load balancer that's
it create so switch to the slides great
so we've we've stepped through that part
we step to that part we step to that
part back-end mapping to a bucket and we
actually activated caching so we just
have one other thing to do is to say the
URL map the map is already done for us
it's a default map it is to say if I get
like an HTTP path where does it go how
do I extend it somewhere so there's
already a default route if we switch we
can show what that looks like so here in
our host and
rules you can see there's a default path
that says anything unmatched we'll go to
this demo bucket that we just created as
a back-end right so review and finalize
that's kind of what it looks like and we
hit create so now this load balancer is
getting created what's happening at as
we speak in this process if we switch to
the slides let's go back one what's
happening now is sorry that the IP is
getting propagated out so this
configuration is getting stood up the
SSL certificates are being replicated
across the globe for serving at the edge
no matter where the traffic comes in and
the configuration to map that back in
service to this bucket is also getting
pushed out so really right now while
that thing is spinning we are getting a
full edge deployment so in our setup we
did a bunch of steps anycast DNS load
balancer front-end plus SSL load
balancer back into a CDN and the URL map
to the content bucket so now let's see
what it actually looks like so while
it's getting pushed out I'm I'm of the
Julia Child school of technical demos we
while while the turkeys in the oven we
have a fully baked one for you which
looks a little bit like this so this is
a load balancer I had created earlier
this has already been pushed out and
everything is deployed so if you see
what that looks like this is here so
here you have a custom sub domain on
this content which is getting served out
if you see where what this maps to this
Web slash index.html if you go here in
the bucket you have a web folder and
it's just a static website this
index.html that's getting served out
right so that's what you're seeing so if
we go back you see that and I'm gonna
start a video which is getting served
out of CDN so I hit click so this is
mpeg-dash and let's see if I can make
so here as the video is playing you will
see I'm using the browser performance
API to to capture the duration that it
takes for the HTTP request to complete
here you can see the mp4 files that
we're retrieving for the two-second
segment length and you can see the data
size right so as the video plays you
have between 100 to 200 milliseconds
round-trip of retrieval for the full
content so let's then click that again
and here you see now because the content
is already cached and if I play it you
can see here the the duration has gone
down to between 0 and 10 milliseconds
right so and and you'll see the
difference as soon as it hits the point
where we stopped the video and and
rewound it it'll the the the caching
will continue but again it's a
two-second it's a two-second segment
that the system is not seen before
but it's able to deliver it in a manner
that you really don't have any drops I
actually ran this test from an airplane
on airplane Wi-Fi and I still got pretty
much the same results between the 100 to
200 milliseconds average so that was
pretty good I don't know if you've seen
this video this is one of the April
Fool's videos we put out a couple of
years ago
it's about self-driving bikes it's very
cool great so can we switch to the
slides all right so we took a look so
let's also visualize the network path
what that actually looks like because we
you know Brian talked a little bit about
the premium network and the standard
network and what the past things take so
I will actually want to show you what
you just saw what the network path or
something like that would be so if we
can switch to the demo again here's sort
of the exploration of Google's network
so let's begin
and it's telling us about standard
versus regular so let's take a look at
what public looks like if our origin is
in Oregon and we want to be somewhere
out here and we hit go traffic we'll
egress from Oregon it'll bounce around
it goes takes a nice leisurely stroll
through Canada and finally lands where
you actually want to see content and
when you're traversing the standard
network or any other sort of generic
cloud provider network this is sort of
what you get and which means if your CDN
is like that that's kind of what you're
gonna get to in fact the reason CD ends
were built was because this was
happening that's why you needed
something very close to actually send
that traffic to this person which then
also meant that you have constructs such
as pre-warming pre-caching etc etc but
when you switch to the premium network a
lot of those constructs really start to
get redefined
because what happens is you do take that
direct path to the closest pop and then
you have a very short public transit
path and milliseconds count right if you
look at the speed of light each
millisecond is about 186 miles of
transit so if you're shaving
milliseconds off in this transit it
allows that single pop to serve a much
wider radius right so so when you do
that sort of optimal curve math and all
that you start to get some very
interesting results and you start to
really rethink how you think of CBN's
not just in terms of how many nodes do
you have but really what's behind those
nodes how are they actually establishing
connections how are they getting their
data how are they connecting with ISPs
and so forth let's switch to slides one
interesting thing is also talking about
anycast so I started using GCP back in
2009 I started with the App Engine thank
you very much I was actually a customer
at some point and that was all I knew
like hey this is how it's supposed to
work why would you do it any other way
but any cash really makes it super easy
because you get from where you are to
where you want to go generally in
a single harbour very close to a single
hop and you can compare that to access
over a regional external IP address and
again we saw how simple it was we just
created a single DNS entry and all our
traffic would flow through that
distributed infrastructure so we'll take
a look at how anycast actually works and
this is not necessarily CDN but it's
actually showing if you do a traceroute
from let's say oops a network a VM on a
standard network in let's say Frankfurt
if you do the MTR on that load balancer
IP you will hit that endpoint in
essentially a single hop my content is
in the States but it will still get
served out of this infrastructure which
is a single hop away from from that user
in Frankfurt if you look at non anycast
transit which means the Frankfurt VM has
to leverage a standard network bounce
around the Internet and go to la you
will have a lot of hops in the middle
before you actually get there right and
if you start to add up the milliseconds
and and all the extra transit time it
really makes a difference and of course
it was easy to set up so we saw that
already the other thing that the CDN
does is automatic optimization so
whether it's one byte or five terabytes
we can handle objects anywhere in that
range and we will automatically optimize
whether we should put in an SSD or HDD
so you don't really have to say this URL
map because it has videos please put
that in HD this has smaller images
please put that in SSD we'll just sort
of see the content length headers etc
we'll figure all that out and it'll be
done the the content chunking is also
handled automatically so which means if
we get a bite range request we will
translate that bite range request into
the chunk request that we need we will
go get those chunks cache them
appropriately see what we have already
from an internal manifest and then serve
that the correct stitched together by
cranes request so if your byte ranges
spanning two chunks we will take care of
that implicitly like there's really no
extra
configuration or manipulation you have
to do so let's talk a little bit about
security for that I'm gonna hand it over
to Brian so let's talk about how we
think about security at Google first of
all we we have always believed that the
Internet should be SSL right and so we
kind of start everything here with with
no costs as a cell right that shouldn't
be a feature you pay for your site
should be secure that's the way the
Internet should be we make it easy for
you to make new certs with Google manage
certs and everything's encrypted from
from kind of from the from our er geo
fees from our front end all the way to
your back end right so you know that
there's an end-to-end encrypted
experience we are for signed URLs which
help you secure your content so that you
can make sure which requests are allowed
to be there you can generate your your
signed URLs offline with with TCP with
custom keys or with keys that that we
provide and and we can actually do that
say in the case of live video or in the
case of chunked video on every on every
day in the manifest - every chunk
request and the signature is validated
right at the CDN edit rate so if there's
a if there's a kind of request that
shouldn't get through they'll get
blocked right right where they started
you can see what that looks like in the
context of Sur Rob's demo right we're
actually signed every every chunk right
in the manifest file and and that's
pretty easy to do we have kind of
example code link to here and again that
that's all gonna be checked right right
where it happened look a little bit
about about dos attacks and dos defense
so we have a product called cloud are
more that that helps you that you can
use for CDN that helps you to write more
complex rules and to be able to block
das attacks where they start but at the
end of the day to even get that far you
need to make sure that you have an
infrastructure that's scaled up and
ready to handle the scale of attacks
that we see on the Internet today so
step one of kind of das prevention at
Google is to out scale the attack right
and that's where making sure that you
ride along with a provider
has enormous scale is a really important
consideration and and we have a great
quote here from from Damien one of the
folks of books at das at Google
basically saying that you know sure
being the largest tax actually requires
the been of course the bandwidth needed
to watch half a million YouTube videos
at the same time at HD and we don't see
that trend slowing at all if anything we
see the scale of das attacks at Google
sort of hockey sticking and that's the
thing that we've been planning for in
our products and in our infrastructure
and this is just an example of kind of
what that looks like in your in your
project so we ran an experiment just to
see you know can we sustain a million a
million QPS das attack on an example
project in a load balancer and GCL B and
you can kind of see that through the
entire duration of the attack everything
kind of stays running smooth and smooth
and steady and then I think the other
thing that's worth talking about is that
because we have this global network and
because all of the all of your cloud IPS
are gonna be any casted that actually
makes it very hard to concentrate a dos
attack on any particular element of the
Google infrastructure right so the das
attack will actually get absorbed across
our entire viewing surface all across
the world where it'll be handled and
dealt with there and so again I think
what that means is that that you know
that when you come to Google you have an
infrastructure that's built to write out
some of the biggest attacks that we know
about today I had back to sir Rob to
just talk about how to put this all
together cool so winning right making it
work for you we give you ease of use all
of Google distributed infrastructure and
serving capability delivered to a single
check box it gives you the any KS IP the
content services the monitoring and
logging programmatic control everything
is done to an API so you can script out
all the work that we just show through a
user interface the scale of course is
billions of users if you look at again
the next most utilized services they do
not have the same order of magnitude or
scale that we routinely work at and the
the critical thing here is ramped
without warm-up so if you have content
if you have any type of end streaming
system and
you do not know what demand is gonna be
it's very hard to kind of get the right
provisioning up front but with Cloud
City and you really don't have to worry
about that the scale will just be
transparent and automatic again
footprint so it's not just how many can
be served but where all can we serve it
and again the most popular sites over
the all across the world some of them
like the Google ones they all leverage
this infrastructure and you get to ride
the same the same underlying stack and
of course there's security so it's not
any good if you can't protect your
content and your infrastructure so you
do get all the investments that we make
you just get that out of the box so it's
the out scaling of attacks the anycast
sort of distribution and the free SSL
[Music]